hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
chief leader writer of the observer
sonia soda and chief executive of
conservative home mark wallace very good
evening to both of you i'm very pleased
to say that mark and sonia will be with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's take a look then what's making
the front pages and duke pays up at last
the metro leads with the out-of-court
civil settlement in the u.s between
prince andrew and his sex abuse accuser
virginia giffrey
that also is the top story for the
guardian
as well as the eye which says the
settlement reached is worth 10 million
pounds
the male calls it the duke's final 10
million pound humiliation
the daily telegraph says the settlement
is actually 12 million pounds and then
the queen is to help pay for it
the financial times leads with the
ukraine crisis with president putin
insisting he's still open to talks while
at the same time not reducing the
apparent threat of an invasion of
ukraine
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us but let's chat through them
then uh with sonia soda and mark wallace
now and not all the papers in yet uh
sonya but most of the ones that have
come in have put prince andrew on their
front page
with this perhaps surprising settlement
surprising certainly in the timing of it
that he has struck with his accuser
virginia jiffrey and you've picked up
the guardian to kick us off
yes that's right so the guardian like
many uh papers is reporting uh some of
the details that are emerging about this
settlement that prince andrew has
reached with his accuser virginia dufrey
the timing might be surprising but i'm
actually perhaps not that surprised to
see the duke reach this um that the
prince rather reach this settlement
we know that
he's made some claims um about reasons
why the allegations that virginia dufrey
has made against him in terms of
the contact that those two have had the
sexual abuse that she alleges
he's claimed for example that her
account cannot be true because he has an
illness that means he cannot sweat he's
claimed that he could not have been with
her the day that she alleges that he
sexually abused her in london because he
was dropping his daughter off to a party
in pizza express
now these are claims that if they were
tested in court he would have to provide
some evidence for
his testimony would be rate over and um
it would be extremely embarrassing for
the royal family so it's not a great
surprise to me that he's chosen to
settle given that he um that she has
made some claims against him and there
is
there is a photograph of the two of them
together in london on the day that she
alleges that he sexually abused her um
so that you know there is there is some
evidence out there that relates to her
allegations so it's not a huge surprise
to me that that he's decided to settle
well yes mark what do you make of this i
mean prince andrew has always
strenuously denied the allegations this
settlement doesn't include any admission
of guilt by the prince he's agreed to
make a substantial donation to virginia
jeffrey's charity uh he said he's never
intended to malign miss giffrey's
character uh he's demonstrated his
regret for his association with jeffrey
epstein so so where do you think this
leaves prince andrew
well um absolutely out in the cold uh to
start um but it it also frankly i i you
know this is um
something which i i i think i'm right
i'm saying that uh
the uh accusers
lawyers describe this settlement as
saying it it speaks for itself and
they'll be well aware that simply by
referring people back to that they will
be uh invited inviting people to uh
ponder what it what it says about prince
andrew himself the fact is that
statement i think it's you know i'm sure
you'll have more to say on this at the
moment but that statement to say that he
never intended to impugn her character
for example um i think we'll raise a lot
of eyebrows frankly at various times his
lawyers as i understand it have uh
certainly seemed like they intended to
impugn her character
it's also the case i would say the whole
handling from the the prince andrew camp
of this whole um affair for
um
this whole kind of
legal affair in case um for years and
years has been frankly could not have
been handled any worse you know from
choosing to go and meet jeffrey epstein
after
he had been uh
after the true nature of what kind of
monster he was was was clearly known
traveling to go and meet him um
from that long association which he now
says he regrets but didn't seem to
regret uh
certainly at that stage
coming out fighting and saying we're
going to fight this all the way it's
completely untrue it's demonstrably
untrue we're going to fight this at
every stage and then mere weeks later
agreeing what's reported to be a
multi-million pound settlement
frankly whatever the opposite of having
a cake and eating it you know this is
this is a double whammy worst possible
way to handle um this case it seems to
me and so he is out in the cold um in a
public sense in a royal sense there's a
quote in the telegraph and someone's
saying that it's been made clear to him
the public have had enough from hearing
for about him i think that's to put it
mildly
and obviously the question now um sonia
is
who's going to pay for this where the
money will come from we don't know the
amount there's the telegraph front page
suggesting it's 12 million but there are
various figures around aren't there i
think 10 million 7 million we don't know
but
people will be asking where that money
will come from
yeah it's a huge amount of money and uh
we know that prince andrew doesn't have
many assets himself apart from a
mortgage chalet in um in switzerland uh
which i think he may have got some money
from so um it does seem uh from reports
tonight the queen is going to be helping
him out and that will almost certainly
come i mean i'm sure it will come from
her private funds but there is this
question about what's uh public and
what's private in relation to the royal
family
i do want to come back to the point that
that mark was making about the way that
andrew's legal case and his lawyers
presumably with his approval sought to
impugn virginia du frey as part of his
legal tactics to try and get this case
thrown out before he's decided to settle
virginia du frey is a victim of child
sexual abuse she's a victim of sex
trafficking and yet we
saw the prince's lawyers i think impugn
her character in terms of her
motivations for bringing this case um in
documents to the court they described
her more of a more as an offender than a
victim and one of prince andrew's former
spin doctors has been suggesting that
the photo the photographic evidence of
them together is doctored so i do think
it's it's really difficult to sort of i
think understate the seriousness of um
if the nature within which sort of and
prince andrew has kind of sought to
advance this against virginia dupre so i
think she will probably be very relieved
with this settlement um today as well
okay and no doubt the royal family will
be generally relieved to feel there's
some kind of line especially given that
it's a jubilee the platinum jubilee
being celebrated later this year we'll
return to this story after 11 o'clock
but um the other big issue of course on
the front pages is the ongoing situation
in ukraine so let's just touch on a
couple of the papers handling of that
shall we mark the financial times puts
it as their main story a putin open to
talks but prolongs invasion threat
against ukraine and we saw a news
conference earlier with president putin
and the german chancellor
and there was this suggestion that
diplomacy could still be
a route through do you feel there's a
growing sense of optimism that an
invasion has been put off
i don't think there's any grounds for
optimism frankly on any front of this
situation it's all summed up in that ft
headline putin open to talks of course
vladimir putin's open to talks what he's
doing is he's menacing ukraine he's
menacing the global kind of rules-based
order he's menacing other neighbours and
nato and the western alliance and by
wielding his uh armed forces as a
violent threat to further invade ukraine
let's remember he already occupies part
of ukraine
he's hoping that he won't have to invade
that we will roll over and keep on
giving him things the fact is that it
troubles me very deeply actually when we
hear western leaders to a certain extent
understandably say their goal is
de-escalation
if if it becomes the question of
de-escalation at any price then that
involves giving vladimir putin basically
whatever he wants i cannot see and i
can't conceive of any form of settlement
and agreement that he would accept that
wouldn't involve essentially selling
ukraine's sovereignty territory
democracy freedom and dignity or
possibly all of the above and so
yes i don't feel optimistic about this
at all this is the product of 14 years
of very careful strategic uh pressing
the west into to see how far he can go
by pressing us to appease him okay and
that story pretty much um second story
on a number of of the the broad sheets
at least tomorrow morning and we're
going to take a break right now lots
more that talk about very shortly though
including you don't need us to tell you
that money is getting tighter but we're
going to talk more about that after the
break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight is the chief
leader writer at the observer sonia
soder and chief executive of
conservative home mark wallace so
welcome back to both of you um we're
going to turn to another story in the
cost of living crisis theme that we've
had um rolling out across the last few
months this is featuring it's in the
bottom right hand corner of the daily
telegraph's front page mark isn't it but
actually there's a big story on the
front of their business section uh which
um
you were pointing out we'll try and get
that on on screen in a moment but this
is about wages going up but not but
being outpaced by inflation so actually
we're all going to feel the squeeze
yes the disclaimer on this is the story
is bylined by my brother so um all
conspiracy theories about everyone in
the media knowing each other
um it's interesting obviously we all we
can all feel this cost of living squeeze
but this is picking out the fact that it
intensifies the pressure on the
chancellor further
over this national insurance rise this
increase in taxes on working people and
disproportionately younger working
people a lot of toys already unhappy
about this the cost of living and the
wage squeeze is going to make that
pressure worse
well what so what do you think should
happen do you think he should drop it
yes apparently you know i i think
frankly if you're talking about the um
the kind of principles that the
government's meant to especially helping
working people making work pay helping
to encourage people and to be able to um
you know put aside savings and save the
future and prosper for themselves and
their families then it seems to me to
run counter to all of those principles
and there is that a business section
front page there with your brother's
article on the front of it um sonia what
do you think about this um
national insurance rise do you think
that it should go ahead i mean because
it's being earmarked the money's been
earmarked for the nhs and social care
isn't it
well well i think the money has to be
found for the nhs and social care but
i'm not sure that it should come through
a tax rise so i agree with mark that um
at a time i mean a 1.2 drop in real
wages in just three months that's a huge
amount that people will be really
feeling as prices go up that wages
aren't going to stretch as far and i
don't think it's the right time to bring
in a tax rise that keeps extra pressure
on people but at the same time the
government is able to borrow and the nhs
is incredibly stretched
there's a reason why we've got very long
waiting lists we have very long waiting
lists that were growing even as we went
into this pandemic the nhs has been
under resource for a decade so it
absolutely needs these extra funds so i
think it's a choice between taxes or
money for the nhs i think it's a choice
between taxes and a bit of further
borrowing at the moment while the
economy is in such a deep crunch